what's the angle of an equilateral
triangle
so if your high school math isn't fresh
in your head
you might be forgiven for not knowing
this but
what do people do when they want to find
out the answer to that question
of course the standard way nowadays is
to go
to a search engine like google type in
the question
find some website that contains the
answer
and then sort of read that website
and answer the question from there
now the goal of this paper here is to do
the same thing
but in a machine way so
the machine would see this question
right here
and it would be able it will be able
to get additional textual knowledge
from a corpus and consult that and then
at the end
come up with the answer which is 60
degrees
right here this type of this type of
task is called
open question answering so like open qa
or oqa
and the distinction here between this
and the previous kind of tasks that were
often
called question answering is that
usually in question answering you simply
have a question
and then you have either no help
at all so the model just has to answer
the question
and things like gpt3 demonstrated that
that is actually something that's
possible if you have a large enough
model
or much more common you would provide
the question and then
one document and you would sort of
guarantee
that the answer is somewhere in this
particular document
so even though the task was called
question answering
it was more like it was more a machine
reading task
because you knew okay all i have to do
is i have to find the answer somewhere
in the document to this particular
question so the task was more kind of a
pattern matching
sort of approach here the
it's really the task really comes close
to what humans
understand as question answering namely
you get a question
you want an answer and it's open in the
sense that you can
the machine can go with the question to
like a search engine i have no clue how
to draw a globe
uh to a search engine get multiple
documents
that would help it kind of rank them and
so on
it's basically able to use a search
engine and then answer the question
from there so that's what we're going to
look at today there has been
a lot of work i'm not not saying this
task is new there has been a lot of work
in open
domain question answering and this is
one of the latest incarnations of it the
paper is called
realm or realm i'm really not sure how
to pronounce this the word would be
called realm i guess
um it's retrieval augmented language
model pre-training by kelvin gu kenton
lee
zora tong pono pong posipot and
ming wai chung so the
paper is first and foremost about
a pre-training method as you can see
right in
the title so the entire system that's
presented here
has sort of been explored in papers
before like other papers have already
done this
or we retrieve other documents and in
this
particular case as you'll see the
documents are retrieved using inner
product search
through a pre-embedded corpus
which is usually wikipedia so you'll see
all of this
the new thing about this paper just to
make this clear
is the way that the pre-training
works for these systems we'll
we're going to look at the entire
architecture but just you know such
such that you're aware what's really
coming from here and
what's gathered from what's kind of
conglomerated from what worked
so far so the improvements here are
pretty
stunning that they achieve with this new
pre-training method
which is pretty cool considering that
it's you know the new thing is a
pre-training method so we'll look at
this we'll look at the architecture the
pre-training method
the kind of hacks that you need to get
it to work and finally
the results as always if you
enjoy content like this don't hesitate
to share it out
subscribe if you are not already and
with that let's jump in so the abstract
says
that language model free training has
been shown to capture a surprising
amount of world knowledge
crucial for nlp tasks such as question
answering
and here again we do we say question
is kind of the broad category of
anywhere where you have to answer a
textual
question so what do they mean by world
knowledge
what they mean by world knowledge they
mean something like
the question that we considered what's
the angle of an equilateral triangle
you can't from the question itself you
can't answer
the you can't answer the the question
it's not like a little math question
where you just have to do the correct
calculations or so on
or uh or which one is the longest words
of the following words
it really is additional knowledge that
you had to have
learned somewhere so that's what we call
world knowledge
and the fact that an equilateral
triangle has 60 degree
angles you need to have picked that up
from somewhere now if you are
gpt3 then what you have done
is you've taken this in giant corpus
right
and you just did language modeling on it
and that gives you gpt3
now that means since gpt3 is so huge
that means that all the world knowledge
that is contained in this corpus
is baked into the model and can be
sort of parsed out with good querying so
if you provide a correct query
you can sort of parse out what's in the
weights of the model but it's very in
transparently
it's very in transparent in the weights
of the model it's baked
together with the language modeling
there
they are criticizing not criticizing but
sort of arguing against this right here
they say however
this knowledge is stored implicitly in
the parameters of a neural network
requiring ever larger networks to cover
more facts
to capture knowledge in a more modular
and interpretable way
we augment language model pre-training
with a latent
knowledge retriever which allows the
model to retrieve
and attend over documents from a large
corpus such as wikipedia
and sorry use during pre-training
fine-tuning
and inference for the first time we show
how to pre-train such a knowledge
driven in unsupervised manner using
masked language modeling as a learning
signal and
back propagating through a retrieval
step that considers
millions of documents okay so that
there's there's a lot of information
here so first of all
what they want to say is they want to
say that in such a corpus
there are two kinds of knowledge right
there is
there is language
and there is this world knowledge okay
and they want to make this sort of
separate
so they want to have a model that can go
to the corpus
retrieve documents and then use those
documents so
whereas previously the world knowledge
has been joined with the language model
they want to
serve this connection say we want a
model where we can simply
teach it to go look for information we
can teach it to go
search for things and then the searched
things
will inform its answering of the
question
okay so that's what that's what these
systems are trying to achieve
and we saw that before in the um
we saw that before in the diagram
so they say we augment language model
pre-training with a latent
knowledge retriever which allows the
model to retrieve and attend over
documents from a large
corpus and also they use this
mask language modeling as a pre-training
as a learning
signal and back propagating through the
retrieval step
now this is the interesting part right
here so
what you'll have is you'll have a
question
and we can actually look at this diagram
right here
so the pre-training is going to be
masked
language modeling okay ultimately what
you want to do is what we looked at
before
ultimately what you want to do is
question answering so this thing right
here
where the input is a query and then you
want to
retrieve documents and then you want to
join them
and let's actually draw this up so you
have a query
and you want to retrieve documents how
do you do that
you train an embedding for the query
which is usually a
you know a birth model like that's the
the fashionable thing to do if you don't
know what bert is i've made a video
about bert
but basically bird can take a piece of
text and then it will
output a vector or multiple vectors for
it in this case we just
need one single vector for the entire
query
okay and then you have a bunch of
documents in your corpus
so in your corpus right here you have z1
z2 and so on what you want to do
is you want to embed all of those so you
want to have
b of z1 and b of
z2
okay you want to embed all of those
documents and then
you want to compare these embeddings
and the you want to retrieve the
document that's most relevant for your
question right if your
question is about equilateral triangles
the angle in them
then there's probably going to be like a
wikipedia article
of triangles or equilateral triangles
specifically so this corpus right here
we're going to consider this to be
wikipedia
now ultimately especially like a company
like google would like this to be the
entire internet but for the these tasks
for the academic tasks this is often a
limited corpus
and then the data sets are also made
such that they can
often be answered with that limited
corpus but in essence this could be
the entire internet but for now it's
wikipedia so you want to
embed every single document in wikipedia
and then compare them
using the inner product so you train
your model
to first of all take this corpus
and then assign each member of the
corpus
a vector so this could be z1 this could
be z2
this could be z3 and so on
and you want to train it in such a way
that if you have a query
then the query will
be very close in inner product space
to the to the document that's relevant
so the query might be your question
about the angles
and the document right here might be the
document about triangles
okay and this document might be the
document about
i don't know england and this one right
here might be the document
about i don't know
weight lifting i have no idea like just
random wikipedia documents okay so you
want them
you want them to be let's let's you know
let's draw a little
dumbbell right here
so you want you want the other documents
to be far apart from the query so you
train two things you train
this model right here which is the
embedding
of the corpus okay and you train
this model right here which is the
embedding of the query these are two
separate models and then you want the
inner product between the two to be
small to be large whenever the document
is relevant for
answering the query and you want them to
be far apart whenever
it is not now the question is of course
how do you know how do you know
when it is relevant when it is not
because you have to have some training
signal right here
right you you have to
basically know in advance which
documents are relevant and
you don't so they start out with this
masked
language model pre-training which we see
up here
the masked language model pre-training
does the following
so this is unsupervised you take some
string right
like this one the and then you mask out
a token this comes straight from bird
you mask out a token and then your goal
is simply to
reproduce that token okay
so if we were in bert you would forget
about
all of this you would simply try to
predict what the mask token is
but here we say well we allow the model
to use additional context in order to
re to fill in the blank and
you can see already how this is going to
help later
but okay so we take this sentence
and we allow it to retrieve documents
and maybe the document retrieved is this
one right here
the pyramidion on top allows for less
material
higher up the pyramid and then you
concatenate
the input sorry the input is this right
here
with the mask token as you can see here
you concatenate that with together with
this thing which is this thing right
here
and then you train a different model
to take this as an input and tell you
what the mask token is now if
the retriever is good then this model
has a pretty easy job
because here you see at the top
something is at the top
and here you see the pyramidion is on
top
then it becomes fairly fairly easy
hey the question again of course is how
do you
teach the retriever to do well and
this is somewhat of a of a loop
so informally
formally the knowledge retriever right
here
is going to we're going to model this
distribution as a joint distribution
sorry this is
oh yeah this is down here all right
so here the central formula is this
what you want is a model that takes in a
question
or in pre-training a masked string
and it produces the answer or in
pre-training this is going to be
the mask token so this is going to be
the question
and this is the answer or this is going
to be
the masked string and this is going to
be the token
that has been masked from the string
okay now you're saying i can decompose
this probability distribution
into the following probability
distribution
and here we take z as a latent variable
um usually but here z is the document
okay so what we want
is a model that takes in your question
and a document
that is relevant for answering the
question and from that
it produces the answer and
in order to fill our probability
distribution we have to have this other
model
that takes in the question and outputs a
document
okay so this here is the retriever
and this here is going to be the the
answer
and in order to make this the valid
probability
distribution you need to marginalize
over all of the documents
in your corpus so now you can see how
you train this
um you simply retrieve all of you train
this model here to predict which
documents are relevant to a certain
degree
in a back propagatable way so in a
continuous fashion
assign each document a probability to be
relevant for answering this particular
question
and then you take each of the documents
and answer
the question why from it and you
marginalize over all the documents
in your your data set and then you get a
final probability and all of this is
completely differentiable
the problem of course is that especially
in this paper here there are like 13
million
uh documents so you won't be able to
train very far
according to that so let's look at the
individual parts first of all this
knowledge retriever the knowledge
retriever model
is a model that will take in
a question and a document
and tell you how likely that how
relevant that document is
for this particular question and this as
you can see is defined as
a probability distribution specifically
here this um exponential distribution
of f and what is f we've already seen f
is simply the inner product between the
embedding
and of the question and the document so
that's the kind of
thing we drew before where
the document is supposed to be have a
high inner product with the
query that it is relevant to
and a low with all the other queries
now since they cannot take
all of the documents what they do is
simply they
go in so
at the beginning you're you know if
let's say you're somewhere during
training right
and you have this index built up
of all of the documents what you'll do
is you'll go you'll project your query
into this space and you retrieve
the couple of documents that are closest
to the query
okay and and you only use those
so you sample a few documents this is
the same thing that we do in
you know contrastive pre-training and so
on
it's just taken here to
the the retrieval
mode so you don't marginalize over all
documents because that would be
computationally too hard
you simply marginalize over all the
documents that
have a reasonably high inner product
with the query that you're considering
why does that make sense
because if you look at any other like
this one here
the inner product is going to be almost
zero
so the inner product with the query is
going to be almost
zero so it does not contribute at all
to this probability right here um
which also means that the gradient is
going to be fairly small
now even though the gradient is fairly
small
it can still be that you haven't learned
something good yet and actually the
document would be pretty relevant
for that query and because you never use
it to train
uh you will you you know
you will never ever recover it because
you don't ever use it to train there's
no gradient flowing to it
and so on so you're sort of relying on
this being sort of self-organizing like
over time
it you know these these turn out to not
really be relevant because you've
learned something
stupid and then your query embedding
either would change and change the query
maybe during training change the query
more towards the direction of the
relevant documents
or the relevant documents themselves
would sort of shift and push each other
around and so on so
you're kind of relying on effects like
this but there's definitely a
death spiral that can go on so
they make a they make
they address this right here and
yeah they address this right here
here the key computational challenge is
that marginal probability p
y of x which is this one involves a
summation over all documents in the
knowledge corp
z we approximate this instead by summing
over the top k documents with the
highest probability
under this retrieval step this is
reasonable if most documents have near
zero probability
even with this approximation we still
need an efficient way to find the top k
documents
note that the ordering of documents is
same as under the relevance score okay
which is an inner product thus we can
employ maximum inner product search
algorithms to find the approximate top k
documents using a running time storage
space that scales sublinearly with the
number of documents
so there are these algorithms to do
maximum inner product search
which you can use to find the top k
documents
to employ these algorithms we must
pre-compute
the embedding so all the embedding of
the documents in the corpus
must pre-compute them for every uh z
and construct an efficient search index
over these embeddings so this now
becomes very much like a search engine
where you have to have your corpus and
you have to build an
index in order to find things fast in
there
like it looks easy in our 2d examples
but to find
maximum inner products in high
dimensional space is actually very
challenging task however this data
structure will no longer be consistent
with
p with this retrieval thing right
because
as we train it um our index is going to
be
old so as we train it our
our index might change but if we only
build it once
then that's of no use if the parameters
of the embedding are later updated
hence the search index goes stale after
every gradient
update on theta our solution is to
refresh the index by asynchronously
re-embedding and re-indexing all the
documents every several hundred
training steps and they have a drawing
of this right here
so they have two different jobs
the trainer here
trains updates itself using the old
index
so an index for a couple of hundred
steps then every couple of hundred steps
it sends over its new
weights and the index builder builds a
new index
using these new weights right and
then the process starts again these can
run in parallel as you can imagine so
as soon as the index builder is done it
sends over
the new index retrieves the new
parameters and starts again
building an index because ideally you
want to rebuild the index after every
single
step but of course that's going to waste
too much time
as well so that was the retriever step
the actual answer step is
fairly fairly easy so once you've
retrieved good documents
right now you don't need as we said you
don't need all the documents where are
we at
right here you don't need we're not
going to do this with all the documents
anymore
we'll simply retrieve the most relevant
documents
because that's going to approximate this
sum fairly well
the answer here that's pretty simple
that's going to be just a
bert model that takes in z and x
okay so this is going to be another bert
model
that's going to take in the retrieved
document
and the question and it's going to
output y
how does that look in case of the mask
language model we've already seen it
right you you simply would input
where is it you simply would input the
concatenation
of the two with the mask as you can see
right here
and then the output is going to classify
a be a classification task so in the
case of
bert you have your query
right here as text and then you have
your document
z right here and there somewhere would
be a mask token you would put
bert on top of that
everything together and then at the
position of the mask token
you would do a classification across all
of your vocabulary right and see
which word is most likely and that's how
you train that and evaluate that
if you are in the fine-tuning mode
then you don't have masks anymore so
what you would
put is your query right here and your
document that you retrieved and then you
would um
you would simply output
now here is an assumption and the
assumption is often baked into these
data sets
you assume that if you have the correct
document
the span the answer is somewhere in
in the z document right here so y is
somewhere in here
and what you would do is you would
classify the start and the
end of the span of y right these
correspond to these
so that's your training signal right
there as i said this is not always the
case but
very often especially in these data sets
it's the case that
it is a single contiguous span as the
answer
okay so that's basically the
architecture as i said the architecture
is
using inner product to retrieve
retrieving
top whatever k documents in this case i
think it's about five they retrieve five
documents
um for each document they run it through
this bird in this joint way
like on the bottom and then they
classify
the output and you can you can do it
with the top one document but
you can marginalize over the top
documents for both
pre-training and for actually
answering a question there's
lots of stuff you can do the important
thing right here
is that this thing is what the
paper proposes a new it's basically
saying how do we do masked language
modeling
pre-training with a system like this
all right okay
and the rest of the paper basically goes
into more detail like how do you
how do you join how do you exactly
what's the input
right here and we've already seen you
just concatenate
whatever you have you concatenate your
query and your documents and so on
so the important thing is it's two
distinct like there are three models
right here right
model one model one
is used to take
a document from the corpus and map it
into
a vector in these in this vector space
right here
okay that's model one that is the model
that you wanna build this index for
right every now and then
you take that model and build an index
for your whole corpus
then model two is
the model that takes a query okay a
question to answer or a masked string
and also generates a vector in this
vector space
right here okay that is a different
model
than the model that embeds the document
and you don't build indices for that you
continuously
train it um and you you just because you
only need to embed every
query once and if you were to not build
an index for model 1 then you would need
to re-embed the whole corpus for every
training step
and then model 3 is something yet
completely different
model 3 takes whatever
documents you retrieved right here
as z along with the query
as text so not the vectors but it takes
the text
of these documents it takes the text of
the query and it produces an answer y
which is either the mask token
or the answer span in the document
okay but this is again this is a text
model
this is nothing to do with the vectors
from before
all right so that was the architecture
and the pre-training
now they go into a few details namely
first detail is
how do you actually how do you even see
that this
does something sensible okay
and thereby they analyze the gradient of
this thing so if you look at the
gradient here's the gradient
of the um of p y
of x p y is this is as we said the
answer
and this is the question and this
probability distribution has everything
in it we've discussed
before like retrieving the documents and
then marginalizing over the retrieved
documents
and so on okay so here you can see that
the gradient
is first of all it goes into the
direction of this
inner product okay this f here that's
that's the inner product between the
embeddings of
x and the relevant documents
z or relevant according to their
relevance
okay so the gradient of the entire model
is goes into the direction of the
gradient of the inner product so that's
already
a good thing right now we can ask ours
we can ask ourselves when do we want
the gradient of the entire model to be
strongly correlated with the gradient of
this inner product when not
that of course depends on the document
itself and this square
this quantity r specifies how much that
is
so if this turns out like we want it
then we can say
okay the training of this model does
something sensible
so what's this quantity r the quantity r
notably
has this ratio right here this ratio -1
now what does it say if
if the top of the fraction
is larger than the bottom of the
fraction then this is a positive number
right and if the
bottom is larger then this is a negative
number okay so
let's look at the the two elements the
top mean
the top the ratio basically means that
the difference here is this z so the
ratio
is larger than one if the probability of
the
answer rises when you have z
in there versus when you do not have z
right here there is no
z so what it basically means is that the
document helps
if the document helps for cla for
answering
the question x then that probability is
larger than the bottom probability
if the document is irrelevant then
that's one
right and the entire thing becomes zero
and therefore no gradient
and if the document is counterproductive
and that's often the case actually
because these documents they can
introduce noise
like noise is often counterproductive
for these systems because you have more
input and then
the um the distribution of
y will become more noisy and therefore
flatter and this fraction would be lower
than one
so this is going to be negative so this
quantity is positive the more
relevant the easier it is to
answer the question with why given the
document
and that's exactly what we want out of a
system like this
so if you look at the gradient of the
system it
shows you that what we want to happen
namely um that the system is trained in
such a way that the relevant documents
will help it is actually happening
okay so that's the left
hand side and there's a little bit to be
said about this thing
right here the probability this is
proportional always to the probability
that your retriever outputs this
document
okay so the this quantity r
is going to be even larger if your
retriever
outputs that document frequently so if
it is a helpful document
and the retriever outputs it very
frequently
for the given question then this
quantity r is super large
and that's exactly what we want right
okay so the next thing they do
is they um
they have to they have to sort of take
care of the initialization here because
the problem we've
spoken of before is that if your
retriever is bad
right it will not retrieve the good
documents
and so it won't retrieve this z here
very often
and then it really doesn't matter what
this quantity is
right here uh because this is going to
be very low like even if it hits upon a
correct document
and probably it doesn't because there's
like 13 million documents and you
retrieve five or so so
very probably you're not by chance going
to hit the correct document
so you never have a chance to get the
document that would actually help you
answering the question
then you get a bad gradient and then you
screw everything up even more
and so on so the problem is that
if you just train this from scratch you
have a pretty bad learning signal
so what they do is they have to take
care of
initialization so they have to
initialize things
such that they are already working
fairly well
before uh before anything else happens
and i this is sort of if i
had to you know criticize these these
systems a bit
it's that there are many hacks
uh to to getting them to work right you
have to
really take care of initialization and
so on because they sort of build in a
loop right the better the retriever the
better the model that can answer the
question and the better the model that
can answer the question
the better gradient you get for the
retriever
but the retriever only samples so it
doesn't even see all the documents so
how can it ever learn that a given
document
is going to be relevant if it never sees
it and so on so
there's quite an interdependence and you
you only can do that
with good initialization as you know is
the case for a lot of these language
tasks
but here even the pre-training so that's
the point even the masked language model
pre-training
where they already have this you know
retrieval step
in there even that needs to be itself
initialized at a good point otherwise
it doesn't help otherwise because you
want to train the retriever such that
the mask language model becomes easier
and you have to take care of a bunch of
stuff so here they say at the beginning
of training if the retriever does not
have good embeddings
the retrieved documents will likely be
unrelated to x
this causes the knowledge augmented
encoder to learn to ignore the retrieved
documents
okay so it basically just falls back to
a model that does not have these other
documents because none of the retrieved
documents are relevant
once this occurs the knowledge retriever
does not re receive a meaningful
gradient and cannot improve
creating a vicious cycle to avoid this
cold star problem we
warm start the embedding of the input
and the docs so these are
these are models one and two right i
think this is what i called model one
this is what i called model two
using a simple training objective known
as the inverse close
task where given a sentence the model is
trained to retrieve the document where
that sentence
came from we refer to this paper so this
paper i believe is the
the um the orca paper and just quickly
for the knowledge augmented
encoder we warm started with bird
returning so this here
i think this is um this is model three
so this is model one this here
is model two that's model three so
this paper here i believe that's the
orca paper
the orca paper is very very close to
this paper it also has this retrieval
step and so on
but it it took it uh
said that it introduced this inverse
close task as pre-training for
its own model so you can see this paper
right here as sort of an evolution where
they go
from um from orca and basically use that
as an initialization
for their own uh model now it's not
exactly
the same and so on but this inverse
closed task
in that or paper was quite a central
point
so what you want to do is you simply
take a document from your corpus any
document
and then you select a span like this
span right here
and then you make two things out of that
first of all
the span is going to become your x
okay and then the document right here
the document but without the span
obviously so
the span you just leave empty that's
going to become
the thing to retrieve and you simply now
train
a model your models so in this case this
is model one
and this is model two you train them
such that the inner product between
um between the two so
your embedding of x times your embedding
of z is going to be large i guess they
have a weight matrices in front of that
but it doesn't matter so you can see
that you train the model
to retrieve the document where a piece
of text came from
okay and you train these model in
conjunction with each other you simply
make the inner products
large and you can do negative sampling
for this in order to contrast this with
other documents where the text isn't
from
if you don't know what negative sampling
is i've done a bunch of papers
most notably the word to vec paper
where that was sort of introduced
so that's your pre-pre-training task and
i'm going to
just take a wild guess here and i'm
going to guess that
in or you know in this ict pre-training
desk
this here is started from the public
bert checkpoint or something like this
so technically
this you have the masked language model
of models one and two would be the
pre-pre
pre-training and then this ict
would be the pre-pre-training and then
the masked language modeling
with the retriever based on ic built on
ict
is going to be the pre-training and then
the question answering using that
retriever
is going to be the actual training
okay so there's a lot of build up here
uh one thing to say is that yeah as you
see here so here is this
pre-training on the left unsupervised
where you simply again the the thing the
way you have to think about it is
what document do i have to retrieve to
make the job
of filling in the blank here easier okay
and the hope is that that correlates
well
with the job of what document do i have
to retrieve
to answering the question um easier
okay what document you have to retrieve
to make to make the job for the model
that answers the question
easier i guess that's the way of
formulating it
all right so the next few things you
have to do to get it to work
is prohibiting trivial retrievals
they say if the pre-training corpus and
the knowledge corpus are the same
which i guess they sometimes are because
you know
um it pays off to do the pre-training on
the same corpus as
your knowledge corpus if
it is large enough a trivial retrieval
candidate
z that is too informative right there
exists a trivial retrieval candidate
if the mask sentence comes from document
z the knowledge augmented encoder can
trivially predict why by looking at the
unmasked version of it
yes of course like if you do this masked
language modeling and you take
your sentence from that corpus then the
retriever can simply go look for that
document
and then it becomes very very easy to
fill in the blank right because you just
do this pattern matching
and that's of no use because what you
want to teach the model essentially is
to kind of
look at the semantics of a document so
you
simply prohibit that particular thing so
this is during pre-training this
is for your masked language modeling
pre-training what we call here realm
pre-training
during that you simply prohibit
um for this reason we exclude this
trivial candidate during
pre-training so that's one thing you
have to do and i feel
here is you know where the specifics of
your
task and your data set come in because
you know
on the internet many things are copied
and sort of copied and translated and so
on
so if you were to do this not in
wikipedia but in a more unstructured way
this
would be one of the pain points i guess
because imagine
you know there is just a a website that
translates all the other websites to
french and then your model can simply
learn to translate
from french and always retrieve the
french document and
fill in the blank using that it will
learn nothing about the word like it
will
not require acquire any
retrieval along semantics of world
knowledge it will simply
learn to translate to french and so on
so i think that this is
rather more crucial than this simple one
paragraph
appears to to have it then
um they also introduced this null
document
along with the things they retrieve so
if they retrieve maybe not five but
eight
i i think they retrieve eight in the
experiments if they retrieve
so they retrieve seven documents the
seven closest ones in in your product
space plus a
null document such that
the model has the opportunity to ignore
all the documents right so it can
basically just go to the null document
assign a large weight to that and just
answer the question
outright so if the answer is already
contained
in the question itself it can just you
know point to that it doesn't need
the an additional document to answer the
question so they leave room
for this possibility right here
now this would also be a good metric to
assess
how much the model makes use of the
other documents and i think they have
this
further down and then the last thing
here is the
salient span masking so
when you do mask language model
pre-training what you'll do is simply
you'll drop out
not even words but word pieces right so
um so here let's take say this you have
this span of text
what you do is you just drop out like at
random
words or as i said even worse
if this is birth or something you have
word pieces so you maybe just drop
out uh this cus
right here and the low
now people have observed that
this is now pretty easy for the model
and most
notably it doesn't require a lot of
world knowledge it doesn't require
even a lot of attention to the other
parts of the sentence
which is what you would like to induce
with this pre-training
all you basically need to do is you need
to say oh there is something and then
cal and maybe you look at the words
around it
and you can pretty easily deduce that
it's local
also to fo on
you can pretty easily introduce that's
too focused so this kind of pre-training
doesn't really mean the model learns
some long-range dependencies or
understands language pretty well
so people have been upping the kind of
smartness with which they
drop out things so the
for most obvious thing is to drop out
entire
words even though you know bird works in
word pieces you can simply
always enforce that entire words are
dropped out now it's a bit
harder then what people do is like
salient span drop outs and that's what
they
do right here so what you
want to do is you want to drop out
things that are sort of kind of little
snippets that are
belong together so for example if i drop
here
local context if i drop this out right
then i need you know some masculine
spans
only require what right
and that requires much more world
knowledge to answer that question
it requires much more long-range
dependency resolution in my language
model and so on
in order to see um that there is world
knowledge and this is exactly what you
want to induce here right you want to
induce your model to learn uh
learn more global knowledge
more world knowledge more semantics of
the language
and you can relate this to sort of
pre-training
or data augmentation i'd say in
image in image in vision for example
there you have the random
cropping so you only crop out part of
the picture and then you crop out
another part maybe here and then you ask
the model
does this come from the same or from
different images these two parts
and the more you crop sort of the more
the model has to
um cannot rely on just single pixels
somewhere but actually has to understand
image scenes and so on what direction is
up and
what not so we see qualitative
difference between pre-training
methods and augmentation methods for
images
it only makes sense that we see a
qualitative difference and different
in differently induced inductive priors
in text if we do this so what they do is
they say
since we want to induce this kind of
thing we will not only drop out entire
words we actually drop out entire
salient
spans such as
right united kingdom or july 1969
we use a bird-based tagger to identify
named entities and a regular expression
to identify dates
we select and mask one of these salient
spans within a sentence for the masked
language modeling task
we show that this significantly
outperforms other masking strategies in
section 4.5
now while i agree with the notion of
salient span masking
i have big troubles with
the way they do it here and i think this
is where you
kind of start to overfit on the
particular data sets so i guess they
looked at the data set and
you know you kind of as a developer you
kind of look at your you know just what
kind of questions are there they saw
often it's you know questions about
entities question about
dates and so on so you know we can just
pre-train uh with those things in mind
and
that yeah that's where it gets a bit
wonky and really specific to your task
really specific to your data sets and so
on
to do that so this is already baking in
a bit of knowledge or a lot of knowledge
i would argue about the task
itself and we're going to see that this
is actually fairly important in the
results the salient span masking
and um yeah this
it's sort of i get it you get better
numbers with it
but also it's kind of dirty and very
um very specified to the task i won't
actually see
and i don't know if people have actually
have done this but the way i would do it
in a kind of more principled way is if
you have a piece of text
what you do is you start by masking one
word okay
um like i'm ask spans here
and then i would ask my own model right
my own half trained model
which um which if i want to
predict this one right if i want to do
mask language model
with this one i can use one of these
saliency methods to ask which other
words
are most relevant to predicting this one
okay and it will probably be say okay
salient is
really important right because if i know
that there is
salient in front of it uh i can
predict that their spans really easily
and then i can say well okay so i'll
mask salient as well
now i have masked these too and i do
that up to some threshold right so the
saliency in my mind should come directly
from the model you're training and by
that you're basically saying that you
know model
you've sort of learned your local
dependencies
now i want you to go beyond that so
you're you're basically really mean to
the model you
you forbid it from using everything it
has learned so far
to make the task more challenging and
more challenging over time
i think this is kind of a built-in
curriculum learning and that's how what
i would see if you
if this is already done maybe someone's
already done it just
let me know in the comments um if this
already exists kind of expanding
the masks uh by assessing the model's
own saliency
all right so let's jump into the results
and the results
as you've already maybe seen in the
abstract are pretty
pretty good so on these open domain
questioning
data sets they outperform all the
previous state of the art not only by a
little but by
significant margins as you can see here
and they do it in
when both the pre-training corpus is the
same as the knowledge corpus and when
the pre-training corpus is
actually a different one um that tends
to work actually even better in
in two of the three tasks so
fairly cool also not more parameters
than you know previous models
especially not this uh this t5 so this
t5
here is an example of just you know
where everything
is baked into the language model whereas
i believe these models right here
they have retrievers um along with it
yeah you can see here they all have
retrievers along with it but they're
pre-training objective and their
architecture sometimes is different
now i believe you can also see the fact
here that orca has the same amount of
parameters
it's very close to the model right here
it's just that the pre-training here is
different
and you also see right here they do some
ablations
where they say okay how important are
the different parts right here
so you can see on the development set
you get what your 38.2 exact match score
um if you only train the retriever but
you reset the encoder before
so that's the thing that actually
answers the question
if you reset that before fine tuning you
drop a little bit
if you reset the retriever you drop
actually you drop more
but still it's i would say it's fairly
competitive as you can see now this is
probably the test set
um but still it's fairly fairly
competitive
right here with the with the
sorry the previous state of the art oh
yeah here here is the baseline it's
31.3 now interestingly
as you can see right here if you have
uniform masks or
random span masks which is the two types
that i
of masking that i discussed where either
you drop out just word pieces or
you know entire words or entire spans so
you just
uh you just take that idea further you
say well i'll mask an entire spam but
nothing with their saliency
um so no no reg x's for dates no
entity taggers and so on you you drop um
quite a bit especially with the uniform
masks you see here
you drop quite a bit now with the random
random span masks you also
you drop you drop for the random spans
and then you drop again
for the uniform masks so this seems to
be pretty pretty
important um so never forget when you
see
things like this that there are these
engineering choices that can make
uh as big a difference as
the the actual idea in the paper itself
okay so you can see this it's pretty the
improvement is it's like three points
from uniform masks to random spam masks
and then three points again
from the random span masks to their
realm pre-training
and the actual improvement with the
uniform masks over
the baseline right here is not as high
now the baseline you know uses a
different thing it uses this
ict as pre-training but
still i haven't seen the saliency
masking
maybe i've seen it maybe it's somewhere
else but i haven't seen it
okay they also have an interesting
thing right here oh they also have an
interesting plot in the appendix
where they show the
num the performance
[Music]
of the different masking styles with
respect to this
retrieval utility and the retrieval
utility
compares this
these two things that we've looked at so
it compares how good is document z
in answering the question why versus
this null document so the null document
is basically just
answer the why right so if
let's let's play devil's advocate and
say that all of this retrieval stuff
it's just
bollocks right um you know
the the knowledge is still baked into
the language model
they we were critical that this helps
and so on then this would also always be
zero
now you can pretty easily or you can
pretty easily see that this would be
zero
right there would be no improvement
having the document versus not having
the document having the null document
so if this is high that means these
retrieved documents are actually
relevant so you can see that if you do
random uniform masking
then it's it's okay it gets above zero
all right if you do random span masking
it gets even higher and
if you do salient span masking it gets
very high so again you see here the
difference between
the salient masking and the others is
you know i would say higher than the
difference between
not having the document at all and doing
the random uniform masking in
pre-training
so again you know something to think
about
at last they have one example right here
where they can show
that actually helps this is just a
concrete example
so the question here is
an equilateral triangle is easily
constructed using a straight edge and a
compass because
three is a and then blank prime so this
is the masked word right here if they
just
ask the model what they should feel what
it should fill in
the probability and vermont is the
correct answer
is super duper low okay then
if they give it the correct document
they just
search out the correct document which is
here the conditional probability with
this document 257 is a vermont prime
that's a regular polygon with 257
sites is constructable with compass
so you can see that it has
it has some overlap like the
constructable with compass
okay the constructable with compass
it's not an exact overlap so it's
debatable whether a classic search
engine would find this
probably but um not and then the
a something prime a something prime
they are here so given this document you
can see
how a model could easily classify fermat
as the correct answer and in fact the
probability
is i guess it's not 1.0 but it's a
rounded
1.0 so if you give the model the you
know model 3
your if you give it the irrelevant
document
it immediately knows what the answer is
and
if you give the um
if you do this whole retrieval step in
between so
this is marginal probability
marginalizing over the top eight
retrieved documents so now they don't
tell it what the correct answer is but
they actually
let it do its whole retrieval thing and
marginalize over the top documents
then it still assigns a very high
probability and i'm going to guess
that's the top
probability for all of the words but you
see there is a considerable
decline so it's not like um it's not
like it's always super sure
and i think there is quite a bit of
improvement
still to be to be done right here
because as a human
if i go look for an answer for this
question and i find
even if i consider the top eight
documents i don't think they would
confuse me
to the point where i'd say that vermont
is only
12 percent likely even though it might
be more likely than
any other word i would assign it
probably a
much higher probability so i think
there's
there's a bit of improvement still to be
made
right here and i'm looking forward to
what people
can come up with all right i hope you
enjoyed this video i know it's
been a bit of a long rant but um i
wanted to make sure the
individual parts are clear let me know
what you think of it
of the model itself and i wish you a
good one bye-bye